Jodee bottom is a widely published
essayist and poet who has written for
just about everywhere everything from
the Atlantic to the Wall Street Journal
he's the former literary editor of the
Weekly Standard and the former
editor-in-chief of first things the
Catholic intellectual magazine he holds
a PhD in medieval philosophy it probably
chose that for its easiness and he's
appeared on the BBC NBC's Meet the Press
and the PBS Newshour Jody is the author
of the best-selling Kindle singles the
Gospel according to Tim the Tim in
question being Tim Tebow and Dakota
Christmas the latter of which has been
revised and expanded as part of his new
seasonal volume the Christmas planes and
the National Civic Art Society will be
selling copies of this book after the
event and Jody I'm told will be happy to
sign them his most recent collection of
poetry is the second spring and we will
also be selling that book and I
recommend that you at the very least you
check out the interior since it's
actually not just a book of poetry but
of songs complete with the music
Jody lives in a Victorian house in the
remote town of Hot Springs South Dakota
with his wife daughter and 10,000 books
please join me in welcoming Jody bottom
I want to thank the college for bringing
us bringing me here and partnering with
the Civic Arts and National Civic Arts
Society it's space is just unbelievable
it's my first time in it and I'm just
think well you know maybe I do support
the National Civic Arts Society if this
is what they could produce in fact I
should say and I thank them for this
coffee - I've I'm out on the road this
past week and next week in this coming
week doing at least two events a day in
promotion of my new book from Random
House called the Christmas Plains and
it's left me exhausted but you know it's
a commercial project and I need to make
the money for it
and that reminds me of just how much I
owe the National Civic Art Society no
one has been kinder to me
in recent years than they and kinder in
explicitly in the sort of thing I'm
doing tonight you heard that their next
lecture is going to be an architectural
lecture these are architects and artists
and people concerned with public space
and they've let me come down in recent
years and do things like talk about
because I had an idea talked about the
necessity for death in political order
they I had an idea which became this
book the second spring of why it is that
poetry naturally wants to flow into
certain forms of lyrics in music and
Michael Curtis talked me through it all
the way and if they said of course you
know come speak to us about this we're
architects we'll be interested and I
told them this year that although I was
out promoting the new Christmas book
what I'd been thinking about and part
out of developing out of that book was a
new way of thinking about mysticism they
called the mysticism of small things and
the National Civic Arts Society that
collection of architects and artists
said well of course Jody come talk to us
about mysticism so you know no one has
been kinder to me in recent years and I
and I owe them an enormous debt and I
and I'm grateful just as I'm grateful
for this coffee and so I don't fall
asleep here in the course of producing
all of this
I want to start this way one Christmas
one morning near Christmas back when we
lived in Washington that brick place on
Park Road with the traffic roaring by my
daughter faith four years old at the
time marched into the kitchen and her
footsie pajamas to announce fort is a
good word
and then she marched out again she was a
proclaimer in those days a pronounced er
a declarer of what she had just
discerned as steadfast unalterable
truths I doubt I've been as confident
about anything in adulthood
as she was at that age as I probably was
at that age as most of us were and why
not language makes a promise when we
first begin to speak it a promise that
everything will come together our
thoughts our words our universe the
unity of truth the medieval philosophers
called it and what they were describing
is the feeling we sometimes still have
even as adults that the world is trying
to make sense for us the beauty of
things their goodness their sheer
existence our hyung our ideas hunger to
be true our words strain to enlighten
and reality the pure essence of things
longs to be thought and said or so at
least I began to think this year while
working on the topic of the use of
language for a section of this new book
the Christmas Plains just out from
Random House and available in many fine
locations and as far as that language
part of the unity of truth goes it seems
easy enough to build an account of the
beauty and moral weight of words the way
our experience testifies that words do
more than they need to if you think
about it my daughter faith was right
thou'rt Julie is a good word roll it
around in your mouth a little and you'll
know what I mean thou'rt forted athwart
a kind of satisfaction lives in such
words a unity a completion the childish
glimmer the glamour of words like thort
proves
well of course it doesn't actually prove
anything but it hints at least that
words contain more than dictionary and
grammar guides say that they do if we
can't name it the proof from poetry we
might at least call it the argument from
poetry for the sparkle of words on the
outside suggest that they have a light
on the inside and the extra verbal umph
we sensed when we were young is an
intimation perhaps of the extra content
we might grasp as we grow older the
first innocence of language we knew as
children in other words points toward a
second innocence we might know as adults
a kind of fulfillment of words waiting
in for us far off in the unity of truth
because what language wants most of all
is to be fleshed with meaning poetry is
what all language wants to be when it
grows up look here's a story I heard out
on the South Dakota Plains where I was
growing up near Christmas one of those
winters when I was young there was
something I wanted to do some trip I
wanted to make and my parents wouldn't
let me so I responded the way
adolescence usually respond by glowering
snipping away in sarcastic comments
affecting exhaustion and being
unpleasant in the way that basically
only a teenager can manage at last
having finally had enough of it my great
aunt ordered me to get my coat and
mittens and meet her outside I found her
in front with the car running and she
took me down in silence to the river
there in pure South Dakota just below
the dam where the Missouri runs in open
water all winter between it's cold banks
the defroster blew up against the
windshield barely keeping out the cold
as the car idle and I waited and waited
crunched down in dread burn protest
dreading the lecture I was sure she was
about to give but she sat there for a
long while looking out at the river
minute after minute until at last she
sighed and began you know Waller Johnson
don't you the rancher from out toward
Phillip your father has done some legal
work for him over the years lord I
member Waller when he was young a big
good-looking boy off the range your
great-grandfather helped bring him to
Pierre found him a place to stay during
the school year partly so he could
finish high school but mostly I think so
he could play baseball and Pierre could
beat yanked and Charlie loved baseball I
want to tell you a story about him she
said back in the early 1930s his mother
and father died the mortgage payments
stopped in the land bank repossessed the
ranch wall there must have been 17 or 18
in those days but somehow he talked the
land bank into letting him try to bring
the herd to market we gave him what help
we could but those were hard times all
over and no one thought he could do it
not with four younger brothers and
sisters to feed but he was a tough young
man he kept the herd together through
the winter fatten the cattle up sold
them and reclaimed the ranch then he put
his brothers and sisters through school
and saw them settled here and there
finally Waller settled down himself
marrying a girl my aunt said named Nancy
trike from I don't know Spearfish maybe
I remember she was a pretty thing but
thin and a little sickly one winter must
have been 42 or 43 during the war anyway
their furnace broke down in the middle
of a blizzard and their baby began
running a fever
she watched the water as it poured past
skinned with ice along the edge you're
too young she said to know what it was
like in those days most of the ranches
didn't have electricity
hardly any had plumbing the roads were
bad and the nearest doctor was maybe
fifty miles away in Pierre the adults
could have built a fire cuddled up for
warmth and outlasted the storm but the
baby was sick and they didn't think he
was going to make it so Waller and Nancy
loaded up the car with blankets and
coats they'd warmed in the oven and
started off through the snow to peer it
took them for maybe five hours to make
that 50-mile drive the blizzard was
pounding down from the north swirling
across the Prairie the way it does if
they missed the road or slid off into a
gully they would die not just the baby
but all three of them left there froze
until somebody came along and found I
want you to picture this she said really
see it as clearly as you can the
blinding snow
that old car creeping along the icy road
the sick child wrapped up between them
Waller and Nancy straining to watch the
road rubbing their breath off the
windows knowing they might be killed but
knowing they had to try why didn't they
stay at the ranch
I asked growing colder and more confused
every minute we sat there in her car by
the river I mean that way at least two
of them would survive if they really
thought they weren't going to make it
then they were just throwing themselves
away they really did think they weren't
going to make it migrate unsaid but they
had to do it anyway it wasn't a choice
it wasn't something to be added up
weighing their own lives against the
babies they couldn't choose their own
survival against a chance however small
of his she turned to me and her face was
hard was something I couldn't quite
understand and do you see why she said
it's because they were parents and
that's what the word a parent means they
had already given up their lives for
that child from the moment he was born
she sighed and looked out back at the
river in that blizzard the bill finally
came due and they had to pay it the way
you will pay it when your time comes the
way your mother and father will pay it
when they have to that's what I want you
to remember she said the next time
you're angry with them the next time you
want to scream because they won't let
you do something the next time you feel
as though nobody understands how
grown-up you've become she glanced over
at me and smiled
pulling the cloth sleeve of her coat up
over her hand to wipe the windshield
let's go she said it's time to get back
home years later I came to see my grade
on story as the answer to utilitarianism
and the ethics of calculation the
solution to those lifeboat cases we were
supposed to ponder in freshman
philosophy classes but at the time I
knew only that she was trying in her way
to let me in on the secret of adulthood
the mystery and the trick of it she was
explaining as best she could the
argument from poetry
is a meaning to certain words their
deepest truest inwardness their moral
content that comes clear only with
experienced parent birth child god these
are big words capacious things that
dwarf the mind that tries to grasp them
and though we may learn their dictionary
meanings when we're young they leave us
room to grow lots and lots of room to
grow now all that is a small mysticism
of words the claim I've just made that
words have an external glitter that
reflects their internal qualities of
truth and beauty and goodness the
transcendental characteristics of being
it's not simple or easy irony delusion
the devices of rhetoric and the snares
of self-interest make it a complicated
thing to untangle but in constructing
this argument from poetry I'm building
on a moral suggestion from the
philosopher Alistair McIntyre and an
epistemological suggestion from saul
kripke all aiming toward a defense of
the possibility that our words have a
kind of moral and aesthetic content that
joined together if only we are serious
enough about the way that we use them
and yet for words to have that kind of
content the things to which they refer
the objects they name must also
themselves have a moral and aesthetic
content the unity of truth demands that
everything around us these chairs you're
sitting on the the grain of this wood
this carpet everything around us also
participates in beauty and goodness in
some way and I have to tell you that I
think that that is true even a few small
steps away from ourselves out of the
self and into the world can give us at
least a hint of what the goal might be
like the unselfconscious joy of reality
the innocent glittering of existence the
wonder and awe of the things all around
us that is all that i mean by the
mysticism of small
things if we turn our attention to
reality if we try to live outside
ourselves we have a chance to see
something of the world as it really is
here's an image for what I mean
there's a boulder a particular one I
know in the Black Hills of South Dakota
back behind the needles those weathered
Spears of gray stone that rise like
faded church spires above the trees in
the central hills near where I live in
one sense of course that Boulder is
hardly unique hundreds of tumbled
boulders lie scattered through those
worn down hills thousands of the
millions tens of millions who could who
knows who could count them they're just
oversized and undifferentiated rocks
after all aren't they falling in a range
of old rocks here on the rocky surface
of a rock stream planet this year early
in the spring and neighbor gave us a
boulder to use as a sort of centerpiece
for the South yard which is mostly just
dead red clay and it's pretty it's a
four foot high amalgam of grey and it's
this tannish yellow streak in it and he
hold it down off some property he owns
higher up in the canyon it's a good
Boulder I think that our neighbors gave
us and I'm glad we have it but you know
I can't say that that Boulder feels
familiar
when I look at it or run my hands across
it as I walk by not yet anyway not
familiar as an old friend when you see
him again shake his hand maybe reach out
and touch his shoulder with a kind of
comfort and strengthening support that
comes just because you're together with
him again there's some way in which I
haven't genuinely seen that Boulder for
what it is I haven't grasped it for
itself haven't known it from every other
Boulder perceiving its uniqueness and
particularity which is all right I
suppose we are after all finite
creatures both in our ability to
concentrate and in the time we have in
this life to do it only God can see all
things all at once and know them
themselves but whatever I lack with that
new Boulder they're in our yard I
actually have with another Boulder
nearly 50 miles away a gray granite rock
I've known since I was maybe 12 up in
the hills behind the needles and in that
difference between those two boulders
may live the best first description of
the natural knowledge to which I believe
the world calls us this mysticism of
small things I found that Boulder I
think when I was 12 I may have found it
earlier my family would come most
summers to the hills and we'd make a
trip or two up to the needles but that
year I was twelve one bright morning
after a rainstorm
I saw the Boulder for the first time
climbed up to sit on it cross-legged and
rest my hands on its rough surface now
that we live again in the Black Hills I
Drive up to needles every so often the
Boulder remains what it has been since I
first came to know it familiar solid and
entirely itself huge as well maybe ten
feet on a rounded side and six feet high
if it matches the usual density of
granite it must weigh nearly 50 tons a
hundred thousand pounds waiting
patiently to fall down the rest of the
mountainside that rock seemed almost
alive when I was twelve years old
glistening in the Sun after a rain and
it has somehow stayed that way for me
the harder knobs of black on the pebbled
surface raised just a little above the
softer worn away gray the flecks of
reflective mica flashing on and off as
the breeze stirs the shadows of the
nearby pine branches and the green
lichens on the dark side and that band
of white quartz and the dimple on top
where water collects only to evaporate
to a dusty film the fallen pine needles
for that matter faded to tan in the
Rock's recesses and handholds we could
say of that Boulder that it's one
unified whole complete in itself
and we could say that it's beautiful
truly we could even say that the Boulder
is good in some metaphysical sense of
the word good although that's hard to
grasp and even harder afterwards to
express how it radiates the
goodness of creation to the eye that
sees the hand that feels but put it this
way that Boulder is just is and all the
rest follows if we mean it if we forget
about ourselves for a moment just long
enough to see the thing for itself and
hear it humming gently in the sheer
presence of its existence now to those
of you who are artists and architects
and writers I suppose that what I'm
trying to convey is a mystical view of
the world that can allow both your work
in the particular and the unity of truth
in general there are big mysticisms out
there if you want to go looking for them
mysticisms that encompass the whole
universe all at once but I've actually
never dared to follow them I mean I
understand what they're about in some
sense Platina tsa's flight of the alone
to the alone Julianna
of Norwich is loss of all being into God
st. John of the Cross is sweet on a
sexual surrender to the divine the holy
unity preached by al-haj even the
ultimate Zen forgetfulness of dojin
Sangji they use different names for the
transcendental ultimate some even deny
that the ultimate is divine but to read
them as to sense that they are all
heading toward the same Gill goal in the
end they all want to be God now not in
any cheap pantheistic way as though
everything were obviously just a little
piece of broken off god stuff and not
even in any cheaper sentimental and
self-righteous way as though to be
godlike all I have to do is be myself
the real me that's the stuff of bad
inspirational posters and even worse
religious cults now the great mystics
were serious people of serious purpose
and they understood and accepted what
their quests demanded you don't get to
stay yourself when swept into infinite
unity with the ultimate infinite you
don't get to keep your possessions or
your friends or your family or your
sanity for that
matter god is so overwhelming everything
in the universe including the self would
dissolve if he approached to merge with
the pure reality of the divine the great
mystics were willing to pay the price of
their own annihilation these are grand
and noble undertakings big endeavors of
the human spirit very big too big for me
too big I hope for you I want you to be
very suspicious of the enormous ideas
kicking around for objects in this world
from the gaya of environmentalism to the
Theory driven installations of modern
art to the broad jokes of postmodern
architecture
besides the universe of ordinary
experience has its own portion of small
satisfactions and epiphanies for the
existence of ordinary objects we are
approaching this conclusion for the eye
that turns toward them for us when we
live just a little bit outside our own
self-consciousness the beings of this
world seem to glow with a beauty and
almost aliveness in their existence some
of them actually are alive of course
plants and animals and people but to
focus on any of them is to realize you
know that they're all strangely close to
animate all bursting with reality their
form and nature the limiting finitude of
what they are testifies to their
creativeness to the fact that they are
not God and pantheism is wrong but
within their intelligible essence they
seem ecstatic simply to exist although
language mostly Falls to a kind of mute
pointing when we try to speak of the
sheer individual existence of things
there remains at least one word we could
use to describe that small infinity
which is each and everything when you
really truly see it we could call it joy
essence is what a thing is that of which
our words speak existence is its joy the
world is full of small things in other
words that are delighted maithili
thankful to be
the paths to human half the happiness we
can identify seemed to require excuse me
living outside ourselves turning away
from self-interest to join the world as
it really is and do you know why that is
so it's because the world is wonderful I
mean that literally it's full of wonder
and awe and the joyous gratitude of each
object in the world that radiates back
to the human observer washing over us
enveloping us raising our spirits it's
hard to be unhappy when everything
around you is charmed simply to exist
all that this requires all that the
mysticism of small things demands is
that we look at the objects in this
world with something of the intensity
with which new lovers gaze at each other
it's kind of wild attentiveness to
individual people places and things
it is appreciation as much as we can
manage as often as we can for the mad
animation of everything that comes to
hand and draws the eye the particularity
the uniqueness the infinity of
individual objects in this world here's
where you know I just spill it all out
hymns to God are being sung by hundreds
thousands millions of voices all around
us the tree across the street from me in
my house in hot springs for instance and
the juniper bush and my neighbor's first
irises for that matter they're purple
blue buds pushing up bravely into the
still chilly air a spring the long and
focused tighter a patch within the lawn
and focused even tighter a single
delicate blade of new green grass sharp
pointed and fresh and young and
marvelously alive small infinities
surround us singing their gift of
existence in crazy harmonies and sudden
dis chords just pick a voice and listen
even a pencil in our hands can come
distractingly alive
pulling the attentive mind down into its
reality the
you just you know look at it the the
wavering little scratch along one of its
hexagonal faces and the taxicab yellow
paint made richer I think with a few
drops of orange the eraser worn down to
a nub by my daughter's algebra homework
I tell her to use her own pencils but no
matter what the parental fete threat she
always seems to snatch up mine the
quickly dulling point the balanced way
it feels in the hand and see there right
along the edge that hint of white under
paint showing above the bare wood of the
sharpened end on and on we could go
about this object alone with more and
more precision more and more detail in
the positive act of its being even a
mass-produced unimportant yellow pencil
is just itself whole and one unique and
special and beautiful and joyous it is a
small infinity that wants to tell us if
only we attend to it about the great
infinity that is God all Mystics are
travelling toward the same country it's
a line from Joyce Carrie they may take
different paths up but they are all
climbing toward a single mountain top
and one proof is the fact that even the
most determined of self contemplate errs
the ones who say take the the mystical
journey inside they want us to discover
something more than our own interiors to
study the way is to study the self
observe doujins ng in the 13th century
and his zazen contemplation is as
complete an internally directed view as
any mystic has ever described but even
for dojin the goal lies far beyond
because he continues to study the self
is to forget the self and to forget the
self is to be enlightened about all
things in the universe self-knowledge
may be useful but self-interest is a
disease as she travels through the seven
mansions of her 1577 description of
Prayer and the interior castle st.
Teresa of ávila finds the same
increasing loss of self for her desire
is to move through the interior to the
ecstatic vision of
who lies beyond all cells and in the end
she explains contemplative prayer is
quote nothing else than a close sharing
between friends it means taking time
frequently to be alone with him who we
know Lots us perhaps this great mystics
are right when they tell us the path
through the self leads to the fullest
loss of self I don't know I do know that
it's a dark road to walk and one other
thing I know is that even a few steps in
the other direction outside of ourselves
and into the world can give us at least
a hint of what the goal might be like
the unselfconscious joy of reality the
innocent glittering of existence the
wonder and awe of things all around us
to see a world in a grain of sand and
heaven in a wild flower as Blake began
auguries of innocence hold infinity in
the palm of your hand and eternity in an
hour and the point is not to forget the
grain and see only the great
indifference of infinity to deny the
passing hours and imagine only abstract
eternity is true this is all the
mysticism of small things means if we a
turn our attention to reality if we try
to live outside ourselves we have a
chance to see something of the world as
it really is to express as artists and
writers something of the real world the
world that we might know and speak in
the unity of truth thank you
so now Jody has agreed to take some
questions from the audience I have two
questions for you first of all which is
the better word wart or clutch secondly
so you spoke of the bolder as if it had
existence and you speak of the pencil
I've had the same it's easier to make
easier to understand how a an animal can
have an essential existence we can speak
of having a certain kind of soul
vegetative or you know sensible or
rational but it's harder to understand
how in an essential metaphysical way
anything that is that can be erased by
the elements and can be made by the hand
of man it has an essential existence
that can be loved and understood does
that existence have anything to do with
the observer or not and how do you make
that argument that's a question that's
the question well I'll begin my answer
and walk you through the entire Summa
Theologica here and we'll know essence
in existence after all the technical
philosophical words they refer to
certain relations and understandings of
reality that come to the medieval
Aristotelian Zout of Aristotle essence
is the know ability of the thing the
what nosov it existence is the this
nosov the thing the sheer fact that it
exists that it's real its existence in
itself is unspeakable
it's the sheer reality of something
essence on the other hand is you know
what what we were get reflected in
knowledge in the mind it's what things
are full and complete knowledge says
Aristotle in the posterior analytics you
remember is that we know the thing is
and we know the cause of its being in
which we translate now its existence
right and that's those are the two steps
you know what it is that's the essence
this is a lectern right this is a cup we
know what they are and if you know the
causes then you know that it is it's
here it's real the material cause of it
and if you know the final cost of it you
know what it's for and that's that
causation is what makes it exist now the
soul and is and the body don't line up
exactly with essence and existence
because to be a human being I'm talking
about essence right what is a human
being that's the essence what a human
being is is this wonderful amalgam of
soul and body our existence is not our
bodies our existence is our reality that
we actually exist and what we are are
human beings and you know that the
essence of course is quite speakable
that's the point of it that we can know
it and speak in and manipulate it and
put it into categorical propositions
like all men are mortal Socrates is a
man therefore Socrates is mortal we can
do that kind of stuff with essences we
can't do it with existences because
they're finally unspeakable and yet we
can know them there's a kind of
particularity that will testify to this
do you remember when you were young very
young and you'd sit on the carpet and
you brush the nap back and forth and it
would go light dark light dark do you
remember how real that was there's a
particularity to everything in the
universe you know this won't be a
universal experience but I bet it will
be enough for some of you my guess is
that for many of you you can close your
eyes and picture the exact legs of your
parents of your grandparents dining room
table because you were the saw it as a
child when you had it kind of
particularity I mean I remember my
grandparents it had those grooves in it
and it ended in those like Empire
grooves and it ended in those
a little animal claws that always
disturbed me a great deal I mean I can
close my eyes and see that with the kind
of particularity I also have to tell you
that it no two other time in my life
have I really concentrated on the sheer
existence of table legs but there was a
particular era T in a uniqueness to them
and the remains one and you know for the
architect it seems to me I haven't seen
Catesby here
it makes me think this way the architect
this is what those details are about
their particularity if you're trying to
construct some grand idea with this I'm
deeply suspicious of it if you're trying
to make the particularity of each thing
in each ornament each shape what it is
if you're trying to just let it be then
as it wants to be then I think you end
up with joyous space because that the
things speak to you of their existence
but you know the these are technical
philosophical words I'm not wedded to
them as the best way to explain what is
the mysticism of small things it's just
the received philosophical vocabulary
that we have out of atomistic tradition
and you know I know it you know it we
deploy it all the time so why not use it
I think this is on okay well I I see a
connection now in the National Civic our
society and you because we can have a
subdivision that's the national you know
classical or these gothic table lake
society that I had a question about you
you've spoken of the the finitude of
things which i think is a great word and
a word that i like well things were
finite before things were fallen of
course speaking from some some Christian
assumptions here so when we speak of
some things finitude we're not referring
to its fall in this but my question is
if we're gonna go with that
from that opera re that there's a
fallenness to our world to how how does
that attenuate the the human knower I
mean
Saint Paul talks about the dark glass
through which we see the world full of
its wondrous and miraculous small things
and we overlooked a lot of those those
things what what are the limits on on
the human the human grasp or clutch of
things this is okay we get we get deep
into theology here and the theological
differences and if I could rephrase it
this is a question of whether man fell
or the world fell is the whole world
corrupted by the fall there's all
knowledge corrupted is all reality
corrupted you know human death is the
fruit of the fall but what about the
rest of it
it's there are certain branches and it
by no means all there's certain branches
of Protestantism that will insist that
everything in the world is corrupted we
cannot you know perceive there is not
the beauty left that they had right
there are certain branches or
understandings of Catholicism that would
insist only man fell again by no means
this is all Catholics only man felt the
world is actually quite what it was
existence God's grace shines through the
world if only we had eyes to see it you
know we fell so we can't perceive it
anymore
would be this certain line of Catholic
thought this is a big divide and I'm you
know I'm not gonna go with either but
I'm gonna lean a lot more toward the
view that there is a grace in the world
a general grace that we may need a
particular grace ourselves to perceive
but God gives it to us you know I mean
you can actually sort of look at things
I do this all the time much to my wife's
dismay he going wow this is really mean
yeah she she says time to go back to
work honey
but you know I think the world is graced
with a general grace
there's certainly aspects of the fall
and they show them in in essences for
instance you know one of the problems
with adapting Aristotelian ism straight
into Christianity is the Albert the
Great started and we carried on
brilliantly through the 13th century one
of the problems is one of them the model
for talking about essences what nYSSA's
in this way for Aristotle is biological
forms but what does that make if we so
if we bring that straight in that means
what Tigers predators were God's created
it forms in the Garden of Eden so there
was death in the Garden of Eden or did
the Predators starve I mean do you see
this is these become complicated
philosophical questions what the answers
to them are I don't know but I do know
that the you know I mean this is like
testifying and you know standing up down
at the River Baptist Church and
testifying but all I can do is testify
that that surely you remember the world
as it was when you were a child and it
you know this is the words worthy and
romantic stuff about you know shades of
the prison-house close upon the growing
boy and but I don't think we have to go
that far because we can perceive a kind
of Grace in the world we can perceive it
because you know the unity of truth is
actually one of the promises that we
have and you can see it you know words
words like wort I've always thought
Apple was a perfect word for what it was
and I you know an apple is just a great
word I love words that seem true of
themselves I have a friend who insists
the word machination tells you what the
word means all it tells you all about
its Machiavellian sense right
machination doesn't sound like an evil
word right you know I love words that do
that but that somehow are true of them
selves and fort is one of those and you
know the joy we can take in that the joy
we take in language all the time
suggests you know you you walk I
remember in New York listening to the
jewelers talking you know in the streets
about carats and every discipline every
business has its own technical
vocabulary we love it lawyers have way
too much of it but they you know there's
this technical vocabulary that everybody
wants because words are so alive they
want to be to be fleshed with meaning
and we backed off of that a lot of ways
in our suspicion and rightly so this is
not an easy Association it's complicated
it takes serious rhetorical training to
perceive it and accurately but words
want to mean something and I think the
objects of this world I look at them and
I think you know they want to be thought
they want to be named they want poetry
right they want our language to be
political as I say I'm just testifying
to my experience of that but I think it
you know you can catch a little bitter
they can't you in your own so I have to
tell you this magazine forever my sister
sent it to me years ago and said you
have to know this magazine you have to
know this college I did nothing with it
nothing the most moving thing that ever
happened in my life was I finally gave
up the IT business I was in for 30 years
and said I made a lot of money it
doesn't represent me I am done and I
became a Fung Shui Master and just
hearing everything you say is what I
believe
our lives are so glorious it is not
about every single thing just being what
it is it is so far beyond that every
piece of energy that exists in our life
and everything in here every piece we
have everything around us has a supreme
energy looking at you looking at you you
you everything and what you say is
brilliant and so everybody in the room
now have to feel
I yeah and I'm you know there's a we do
we have so little that comes to us
unfiltered by our own self-interest and
by the modes of perception and you know
a childbirth the sort of the primal
exposure of it the bolt of lightning
outside the kitchen window when you're
doing the dishes you know that suddenly
you've had this happen to you right
you're startled by a bolt of lightning
and then for for a few minutes
afterwards everything seems a little
more vibrant real I mean you're sort of
perceived things if you've ever had an
ear had an ear accident and you know
almost lost your life you know you've
narrowly missed by a car or something
I'm not talking about the heroism of war
which you know has s its own deep
meaning but just you know some near
brush and then suddenly everything in
the world is like oh look at this piece
of paper it's like it's you know the the
this kind of we need to be shaken a
little bit holding a dying person and
every once in a while in prayer you know
there's this reality that can shine
through so I'm hardly in a position to
say this doesn't lead to anything more
but when I said it's not simple it
passes it has to be passed through the
devices of rhetoric and irony and many
other rhetorical forms just for words
and the artistic forms for the objects
and the architectural forms it has to be
passed through that so this is not sim
simple and I'm not denying symbolism I
when I say I'm against big ideas I'm not
denying symbolism I think in fact the
symbolism can provide the what of it but
I'm also demanding that we perceive the
that of it the this
that it's real in particular and you
know those stones and back with you know
the state names every state provided it
was stone to the foundation there you
know there and the letters on them are
differently discolored one of the things
I hate is when they go in and clean you
know and then it then they're not
differentiated anymore I really actually
sort of dislike this because I so
attached to the particularity of it with
regard to that kind of civil war
symbolism well think of it this way if
something really quite unique about the
United States that in our national
military cemetery
we have Confederate circle we have a
memorial for rebels right in our
national military cemetery there's
something quite you know the round heads
weren't burying a lot of you know the
noble men when they killed them in
England when you have civil war you
don't typically do this now part of its
the Civil War settled the post-civil war
settlement and how we came to address
that and you know we didn't solve the
racial problem that we might have then
because we adopted a certain settlement
and so there are ways to disagree with
this but it's still you know operative
and a very kind of odd and interesting
way and one of the things that does that
for me is you know three or four in that
circle and Confederate circle three or
four of the headstones are tilted have
you seen this can you picture it and
there's a kind of uniqueness there in
particularity and I know someday they'll
come in and straighten them all up again
because you know this is if we shouldn't
do this historical preservation would
all be out of work and where would we be
then but at the same time you know it
sort of speaks to me about the South and
war and are supposed war settlement and
so I'm not opposed to symbolism this is
not a rejection of it but it's a simple
demand for the artists here and the
architects and the writers and any of
you want to think about this that the
oneness of it isn't enough
and we forget that when we move up to
you know postmodern jokes where the
whole point of the architecture is an
idea or two you know
abstract art you have a certain kind of
the of them of a very modern kind which
is installations and performance art
where the whole idea of the whole point
of it is the idea and I want to say you
know that's not art the painting you
know that that's moving up and I'm
really suspicious of those moves I don't
want to deny the symbolism I don't want
to deny the what Ness but I want to
insist that it's those brushstrokes in
the painting that make it real you know
and if you hold a you hold your program
at the museum
you know you hold it to block out the
light and you can see the shadows in the
in the in the paint strokes that that's
the existence of it and that's real and
that's what makes it more than just a
symbol symbols you know that there's
that great line of Flannery O'Connor's
do you all know this story she finally
went up to New York you know to receive
National Book Prize and Mary McCarthy
throws a dinner for her and it's the New
York literati and there's Flannery
O'Connor off the farm in Georgia and one
of them tries to tries to be really nice
because you know about this Catholic
girl off of Georgia farm she says well
I've always thought says to Flannery
O'Connor I've always thought the
Catholicism was a beautiful simple or
that the the host the trans
substantiation was a beautiful simple
and forgot her is reported to have
replied if it's assembled the hell with
it I've got enough symbols in my life
you know this is it it's not
yes it's symbolic but it's got to be
something more than that
you know I mean in a weird way what I'm
calling for is the transubstantiation of
the world every object in the world
should be alive somehow now that's
transubstantiation small T I'm not fully
off into heresy yet but but you know we
want the world to be particular I
believe we have time for one more
question
post conversational age with you know
pagers and television and radio we're
sort of assaulted by by you know things
that aren't actually talking to people
they're talking to us but conversation
do you see that decline in our society
today and what what does that mean in
terms of word in words having meaning
yeah you know words are cheap this is
one of the problems I face is a writer
trying to live off my pen words are
really cheap they're not paying a lot
for them and it's you know but I don't
know that that there's anything
particularly corrupt about the rhetoric
of our age you know I one can get in
political depressions and sort of one
can get in depression for almost any
reason and you know when you get
depressed how every bad thing seems to
kind of clump together like you know
it's all part of the same thing your
party loses the election the Yankees win
the pennant all this bad stuff happens
and it all seems related somehow but you
know I don't I'm not sure that we're
particularly corrupt although language
is very corrupt right now but you can
look at you know history is seen other
ages where language is corrupt I feel a
particular shame that English should be
so corrupted because you know I have the
love for English that only a mono
linguist can have but you know English
is corrupted right now we have political
rhetoric that's quite corrupt but on the
other hand you know look at go back and
look at a mark Hanna
yo I mean language was quite corrupted
at various points at other times in the
history of the Republic is there
something unique in the technology
certainly we are bombarded with written
words in a way that we've never been
before one of the interesting things is
for the last 20 years of the computer
revolution we've been promised that it
was all gonna turn into visual stuff and
in fact never before have we been
bombarded with so many written words you
know people don't actually want if you
if you know CNN puts up on its website a
video and a transcript of the video the
transcript will receive three times the
number of hits of the video because
people want to it's faster to read it's
more informative to read people want to
read and we've been promised it's all
going to turn into visual stuff and in
fact it's the written word bombarding us
all the time but that by itself is not
proof of the corruption of language and
you know I mean the fact that it's being
used a lot isn't proof of the corruption
of language I think we have a problem
with poetry which is after all language
at its highest and that's something that
we have to address I know I said
poetry's language at its highest and all
the philosophers in the room remember
but you know that's something we have to
address but there are people after all
addressing it you've had Dana Julia in
here you know Dana and you Mike asked -
I understand that can be sure Social
Security who writes that does those
great Latin translations I understand
they've both been here - the Hillsdale
and you know we were all in those
formalists poetry fights in the 1980s
and that battle you know it didn't get
one but you know even poetry magazine
now will publish a sonnet if it's good
enough so you know we a turn has been
made out of that and and that means I
think that we can win these rhetorical
fights you know and we need to purify
the language of me - that's what
criticism is for all right it's a
cultural purification we just
need to keep up the fight and I think we
have a promise that it's worthwhile
keeping up the fight because as I said I
think this world is graced and every
object in it is you know sort of seen
it's not God I don't believe in pantheus
and I think in fact pantheism is wrong
but I think every object here is telling
you that it's created and it's singing
this little hymn of joy and thankfulness
for its creation thank you all